the jogan experience I put myself in
situations that aren't that I've had
[__] directors call me a panac [__]
what yeah I had a director call me that
one was he also no he was a white what
yeah how long ago in the 9s wow I don't
want to call the director he's a big
director holy [__] dud and he called the
other actress a [__] oh my God he's a
get on your mark you pan go whoa yeah
yeah this is back you know when it
wasn't who is he alive yeah so he's
doing movies still I I want to so badly
tell you who it is but what's his name
rhyme with I'm not playing this game I
know the internet tell Will you tell me
later oh yeah okay oh yeah yeah they're
going to go through your IMDb and
they're going to find some likely
candidates maybe we should do that yeah
let the internet do it maybe we could
play warmer warmer yeah warmer no no no
one time this director same I worked for
thisor Italian no I'm not playing this
game [__] you okay one time I [__] up
on a line and he he made the whole whole
uh everyone like the cameraman everyone
in the wardrobe former Circle they put
me in the middle of the circle and he
goes Point your finger and they all
pointed their finger at me and he goes
repeat after me you're the worst actor
on planet Earth oh my God and they all
did that and tears wed up in my eyes and
I remember a wardrobe lady looked at me
she goes I'm so sorry oh my God yeah I
mean I had I've had I had Michael ba do
something to me W what did Michael ba do
to you he grabbed my face aggressively
whoa why what did you do to him did you
grab his balls did you wake up you
sucking on I do that I don't do that I
do that for Comics okay okay yeah I
don't do it when I'm like on a no I did
this so I booked this commercial with
Eric Stone Street right you know Eric
Eric he's a modern family okay he plays
the fat gay guy sure sure so we played
Tower boys with um Kim catrell so it was
a i for it was a Pepsi commercial I
think and she was in this bathtub and I
had never before you know Joe like I'm a
stand I come from the same place you
come which is open mics and stand up
yeah I didn't learn how to I don't know
the [__] that right I don't know what a
jib camera is or a Mark or any of that
[__] right so I had this scene where I
had to bring these oh [__] I had to
bring these towels into a [__] you know
he was like stacked that was a joke and
he would go your face needs to be in the
light and I go oh I don't I don't know
so I try to tilt
every take the light the light right and
then like by the eighth one he came from
behind the thing and he grabbed my face
like this he goes here here and I like
tears well will no don't feel bad for me
poor I'm a
Survivor right that's your
Holocaust that was your out being in a
movie and Michael Bay tells you to put
your face towards the light yeah but in
the '90s I experienced that [__] right
well that seems like you really w
putting your face towards the light and
he was freaking out cuz they could only
do that take so many times I'm kind of
on team Bay on that you are really yeah
he just turned your face oh you're right
you're making it sound like you're right
you're right you're right you're right
you're right you're right beat your ass
you're Abol but but also when you when
you come when you come from a background
like me yes with your dad [__] acting
crazy when people scream right it
[__] it feel you feel it you got
triggered yeah like ter what's a Robocop
what's his name the original RoboCop
Peter Peter we we yeah he's a screamer
screams yeah so yeah so I was on M you
yeah I was on Magnum he does it to
everyone right oh yeah back in the day
we wouldn't have sides you can't
remember one line he would like yell
stra like that right really and every
time he would do it I would like tense
up I'm not a [__] dude I get it I'm a
warrior okay wow yeah and then and then
right I just went to the show I just
next time I'm on the side maybe not him
so they just did it you know but anyway
now I do [__] that's like where I feel
like I'm wanted right and I'll do it
right so it's not like that crazy
[__] where I need back then I needed
it right when someone would say
something horrible to you you just have
you absorb
it